thirteen years he comes home a man of 32
and they said Oh tell me I couldn't talk
in a television studio in Washington on
August 28 1963 a small group from
Hollywood California joined to give
their own personally held views of the
Civil Rights Gathering which took place
on that day here as citizens committed
to the cause of civil rights our James
Baldwin and yet I had to do some very
difficult living Harry Belafonte is
intelligent and articulate but it's
Marlon Brando Charlton Heston but I had
to be a relentless Joseph mankiewicz and
to be sympathetically and play yeah and
Sidney Poitier repressed them without
seeing Amin to the moderators they David
showing them and I think that it's about
time to begin our discussion we're here
in the studio today with seven men who
have two things in common they're
entertainers and artists and they've all
come to Washington they're seven out of
some 200,000 American citizens who came
to the capital to March for freedom and
for jobs they came from many states of
the Union and in many states of mind
they came with many different
involvements some of them who came here
to Washington were long-term fighters
for civil rights some of them have
joined only very recently but perhaps
just as intensely perhaps we can start
with these men and ask each and every
one of them to tell us very succinctly
to begin the discussion what brought
them to Washington and how long they've
been on this road this March for Jobs
and Freedom let's begin with a very
well-known American novelist one of our
best writers James Baldwin mr. Baldwin
what brought you to the march on
Washington I could say that cloud was
born Negro in this country more
concretely I felt
there was no way for me not to be
involved with what impressed me is being
a most significant the most important
most loaded demonstration to free
Americans that is ever happen in this
country well we'll talk more about that
later but first let's quickly get from
each and every one of you mr. Brando
have you been on this road for a long
time I don't know there was a time when
nobody was on the road really it was
time when Rosa Parks stood up on a bus
and Montgomery Alabama and from that
date the Montgomery bus boycott took
place and somewhere in the 50s 18
Negroes in the Georgia prison camp broke
their leg with sledgehammers to bring
attention to the condition that they
were in and slowly bit by bit I became
involved in this issue and I guess my
springboard was listening the Martin
Luther King speak about the role and
distress in California Jo man kovitch
writer producer director well I like all
Americans I've been involved in what I
call human rights I wouldn't sell it
born in this country I think that what
has happened me recently is that I've
become violently aware of the urgency of
human rights in America now the fact
that this is an inalienable thing and
something that must exist if America is
to exist in apart images to exist in of
our moral fiber is to exist and this
urgency and my awareness of it brought
me here I felt this sense of urgency
myself mr. pledge a and I noticed today
all day long and all of the speeches and
all of the placards I saw the word or
heard the word now now now repeated with
insistence II was it for you a case of
urgency and now or has this been
something that you've been fighting for
a long time well the nature of my life
over the last 36 years has been such
that
an urgency the urgency there was evident
today has been bubbling in me personally
for most of these years at least most of
the years I came into adulthood I became
interested in civil rights struggle out
of a necessity to survive and I think my
interest started many years ago never as
intensely however as it exists today how
about a personal participation such as
today's extraordinary participation is
this a rare experience for you no it is
not a rare experience for me I found
having lived in New York and in other
parts of America over the last 20 years
since I came from the Caribbean I found
it necessary for self-protection and for
to perpetuate my survival that I involve
myself in any activity that would ease
my burden momentarily and what was the
involvement of mr. Charlton Heston two
years ago I picketed some restaurants in
Oklahoma but without one exception up
until very recently like most Americans
I am expressed my support of civil
rights largely by talking about it at
cocktail parties I'm afraid but again
like most many Americans this summer I
could no longer pay only lip service to
a cause that was so urgently right and
in a time that is so urgently now mr.
Belafonte many of us have felt I
particularly as a reporter around the
world I've seen things happen in certain
countries at a given moment where what
the French call a please the Kinshasa
takes place a sudden awareness of the
problem I know in your cases hasn't been
sudden you've been very active in the
civil rights movement have you not yes
sir
could you tell us a bit about your own
role in civil rights
well civil rights are something that I
inherited it needs to struggle for civil
rights I got it from my mother their
father and they got it from their mother
and their fathers and to be in
Washington today was for me an
accumulation of
a number of generations of black
Americans who have been trying to appeal
to the conscience of white supremacy and
a superior force that has denied and
disenfranchised the Negro for so long
and that to be in Washington was for me
today a a beginning really a kind of a
climax to generations of Hope and having
been deeply immersed in the civil rights
struggle and having been at the
beginning of so many important civil
rights issues in this country and
demonstrations it was indeed a very
powerful moment to see 200,000 people
mostly black people but also white
people and to know that a nation such as
America and the reason that I struggle
with it so hard and I grapple with this
so hard is because I really believe in
the potential of this country and this
country has not realized its potential
it has not even begun to scratch its
surface in the humanities and because I
do feel strongly about that potential
because of the kind of inheritance
inheritance I've had it was necessary
for me to be there today mr. Belafonte
you are I think one of the lieutenant's
of Martin Luther King was once respected
leaders of the movement we all heard mr.
King say today that this was perhaps the
greatest day for freedom in modern
American history
perhaps we could ask mr. Brando to say
tell us what that means to him do you
think then if it's the greatest day for
freedom that this is the beginning of
some tremendous change in our country
and if so how you see your developing
well this is a revolution of course that
is sweeping our country now and that if
it ends up properly perhaps Indians will
be given some of their land back that
they have rightful claims on by treaty
certainly the benefit of all minorities
Jews Filipinos Chinese Negroes
understanding currents all people will
benefit today was an unprecedented event
in that it is the only time in history I
believe in America went to over 200,000
people have gathered to say with one
voice and with one spirit one cause and
I think that it's easy to oversimplify
this problem the problem seems to me a
subtler one and that has to do with
hatred it's true that the album bundle
tribe was wrong from an area of I think
Tanganyika to Angola was responsible for
the acquisition of 15 million of their
fellow Negros citizens and sold them
into slavery
certainly the cruelties that have gone
on in between the white races will
testify to this inherent anger that all
men feel and no matter where you look
whether it's in Franco's Spain or Chiang
kai-shek's government or in some of
these South American countries they the
the distress that you see in Haiti today
gives evidence to the fact that we are
all as human beings filled with anguish
and hatred and fear and I think that
that is what we are expressly addressing
ourselves here to today here in this
movement I think it's one step closer to
trying to understand the human heart to
try to understand what is it that has
produced this what excuses that we give
ourselves to give the expression to
burning children with cattle prods and
destroying you know as I listened to you
something strikes me and I'd like to
throw this out for discussion or anybody
who wants to answer it you've mentioned
a number of countries in which there
have been depressions and repressions
and in which man has been hateful to his
brother and in which this anger
expresses itself at a demonstration of
one kind of the other what strikes me is
that almost I think all the countries
you've mentioned
countries and the Western world
countries where we know about refreshing
and which where we have an opportunity
to demonstrate against them as we've had
in Washington here today this is not a
really a flag waving question of mine
but I've been a foreign correspondent
for a quarter of a century all of you
gentlemen have worked overseas it does
occur to me that demonstrations of this
kind could not easily be held elsewhere
and when we talk about oppression and
repression I haven't seen any march on
Moscow or march on Peking and with all
the faults that we have in which we're
trying to examine wouldn't you agree
it's fair that the hope of our country
is that we we can have demonstrations of
this time well all right yeah I'll have
a mark to Jim Morgan on our way down
this morning I suddenly turned us all
these fantastic preparations going on
and I found myself saying that this is
wonderful
this is horrible this is joyous and this
is depressing but this is the only
country in the Western world almost I
think in England it could happen I mean
possibly I find the whole world yes
which this could happen a meeting like
this but it's also the only country in
which it is necessary this is this is
the frustrating thing that surely we can
even have a meeting like this today in
this country but at the same time it is
necessary in this country you see what
the but what it is well the most
important thing is that freedom true
freedom is not given by governments and
freedom is taken by the people and the
excitement of today in my mind is the
fact that one out of every thousand
Americans was here in Washington and
that the people of America are becoming
aware that this freedom to their fellow
human beings and I call them human
rights are theirs to give the civil
rights bill is not as important as the
fact that the people have freedom to
give and I think now will begin together
mr. Heston was about to come in on the
so earlier you said very modestly and
with considerable humility that until
recently you'd reserved your civil
rights position for a cocktail party
that's no longer true would you love
expand on that first I'm afraid I have
very little to expand in terms of direct
action be on my participation in the
most moving events of of today but I
would to some extent disagree at least
as I understood the jozin Marlins point
the prime thing I extracted from today's
events was a quite hopeful and stirring
feeling of for the future and also a
restatement of the principles on which
this country was founded dr. King said
most eloquently that now seems finally
to be the time when the the check which
the Negro American has presented so
often and had returned to him marked
insufficient funds may at last be on the
verge of being cacheable and in terms of
equality with his fellow Americans but
as an American I am as stirred by the
fact that this is true
as I am by whatever capacity I have to
emphasize with my negro fellow citizens
in their eloquent cry that it finally
happened now and I I cannot forget that
as you suggested this is a country and a
system of government that was however
tardy we are in extending freedom to all
its citizens we conceived the idea of
freedom for all citizens under the law
and among the many eloquent things that
were said today James Baldwin has
written as eloquently as anyone on on
this subject but
most of the men who have written on
civil rights and spoken on it trace back
what they speak about to the statements
made by Lincoln and Jefferson and
although the the end is not yet the as
Harry suggested this is perhaps a
beginning and the times ahead are just
as as difficult as the times behind
although in a different way where do we
go from this beginning the tremendous
energy churned up here of course is a
motivating force but it's Vegas defuse
unless the plan of action cause causes
people to really correct in fact and not
only in oratory will this tremendous
outburst now lead to a course of action
mr. Belafonte I really don't know now
that we speak of is not a now that
describes a success or fulfillment of
the issues and the grievances that face
the Negro people then now is is a
statement that from here on in there's a
point of no return that there's success
or there is utter failure there is no
middle of the line there is no
compromise on the issue then now that is
being spoken about is the fact that in a
hundred years
finally through whatever the causes have
been in history and most of them have
been because of oppression the Negro
people have strongly and fully taken the
bit in their teeth they're asking
absolutely no quarter from anyone even
the hand that is extended in terms of of
brotherhood and friendship to the white
citizens who want to participate it is
four of them to make the choice to
accept because they intend to move
without it and that and I don't mean to
say that the black community is not a
community that doesn't have
responsibility in this current
revolution but I do say that the bulk of
the interpretation of whether this thing
is going to end successfully and
joyously or is going to end disastrously
may is very heavily that the white
community it lays very heavily with the
profit ears it lays very heavily with
the vested interests plays very heavily
with a great
stream in this country of people who
have refused to commit themselves or
even have the slightest knowledge that
these things have been going on and
those who have decried demonstrations
and who have said the Negro is going too
far they are the ones who in fact of
being provoked the most by this because
for the first time and it is only
through our demonstrations that they
have come to our level of consciousness
and in this now that you speak oh it is
this point of no return because we are
on the march and there is going to be no
return from it because the march in
Washington today is one thing but it
doesn't end there they're gonna be
marches again and they go to marches in
the local villages and the local cities
and they and and it's not just in the
south it's in the north it's all mr.
Baldwin we've heard mr. Belafonte
talking about point of no return I've
seen every head here nodding when he
said that he also mentioned
responsibility and I think that
everybody has demonstrated that in
Washington today but dr. King who was
fought in the name of non-violence love
and brotherhood also talks about a dream
he has we heard this eloquent statement
of the great dream that even in in
Alabama they were going to accomplish
this you're not a prophet you're a
novelist but novelist very often see
into the future do you share the dream
you are you thinking will be achieved I
think we were over at this table and
many more people in that share that
dream when Martin said that he he
dreamed of a country in which his four
children would happily penalized because
of their color all of us all of us
please I think we're all committed to
that the one what is perhaps paradoxical
but it's American Negro in this context
who on the basis of the evidence has
more as most faith in this country I
myself always no matter how bitter I
became leaved is how he puts it in the
potential of this country in the
tremendous energy here and the things
that we can achieve if we will the
importance of the day in my mind is that
for the first time in our history and
the first time in 100 years the nation
shows some signs of really dealing with
its central problem instead of as it is
done for 100 years avoiding it if they
denying it lying about it pretending it
does not exist the country will have to
know go to work and very hard work very
dangerous work
to change itself to achieve this dream
that Martin was talking about and if we
do not achieve this dream we have no
future at all
did you believe we will achieve it I
certainly believe it I certainly in a
non-violent manner about it yes I
believe that too but it is going to cost
us every single one of us including I
wanted everyone here and everyone in
this country I'll not be achieved
without violence because the Negro
people have conducted themselves none
violently the 200,000 people that were
there today there were many predictions
in one could take book on whether there
would be a display of violence by all
the extreme factions and what not but
the truth of the matter is that the
people who came to that gathering today
were people in great anguish will come
from the Birmingham's and come from the
Jackson Mississippi's and they came
there with anguish and with hurt and
with dignity and with integrity and it
was one of the most orderly displays
I've ever seen of 200,000 ordinary
people with weights everything like it
and if the Buchanan's continued to
release dogs on the people as an answer
to their legitimate cries if they
continue to use cattle rods to problem
if they continue to use hoses to whip
them through the streets the human heart
and the human body can only contain so
much there must come a point if they are
pushed to it for retaliation so once
again I put the emphasis on who it is
that will precipitate because I do
believe that the Negro community most I
think that I can speak for for from most
of the 20 million Negroes are committed
to this thing being done by
they have already displayed that they
display a very eloquently system
Montgomery bus strikes oh yeah I also
must say one other thing because I know
we must move on and others will speak
but when you speak of Peking you speak
of Moscow and you speak of other centers
in the world where demonstration like
today could not take place yes I accept
that but I also say that it is long
since past the time when we can measure
our own conscience in our own sense of
morality based on what some decayed
society refuses to give its own
we must it is like arguing that the
present administration as to what we
feel they did or did not do in relation
to the civil rights struggle because
they were measuring it based on the
previous developer day I could not agree
with you more in terms of measuring in
our society but remember the entire
world watches this sort of thing the
world doesn't have a correct measuring
stick we all have lived around the world
when I mentioned Moscow Peking or any of
these things it is because here we are
talking to the world more than 100
countries will be listening to me the
discussion available I understand that
once I agree to tie this off I agree
with you wholeheartedly I said that in
the beginning but the point that I'm
trying to make is that we are also the
loudest crier of any nation about
democracy and about the free country
what we were hearing in effect is we've
been letting the Negro have his dream
say go on dreaming well the time has
come I think and we've shown today to
stop dreaming this dream and wake up to
it because this dream was put into very
precise words called the Declaration of
Independence
it was restated as the Emancipation
Proclamation and sin this past hundred
years that we had permitted the Negro to
have his dream a dream that was restated
by dr. King today but dr. King injected
one new point which is it
perhaps.perhaps
and aroused American people can permit
the rest of the American people
mr. Poitier came into this country how
old were you when you came to America
you're 14 years old you came to this
country what has been the evolution of
your own thinking as you as you met this
problem and as you face it today and
what do you as a person not as an actor
or even perhaps not even as a Negro but
how do you feel inside of yourself you
you're forced to participate yeah well
yes I am forced to participate because
it is my conviction that my country has
to successfully negotiate the Negro
question is to me not a problem it's the
question of the Negro the unsettled
question of the Negro in America we must
as a country successfully negotiate that
before we can with any degree of honesty
try to become eligible for participation
in the future we must negotiate other
great questions that face us today and
the stamina the texture of our endeavor
to solve the Negro question will will
exemplify for me the kind of interest
the country as a whole has in doing the
things that are necessary for us to be
entitled to a future mr. Hester you want
to say well everything that we've been
saying in the last few minutes
illustrates vividly the the vital
importance of this question not only for
Negro Americans but for all Americans
and us in view of our position in the
world for all the world and again the
importance of it and the difficulty is
both Harry and Jimmy Baldwin suggested
that it's not an easy a downhill coast
the difficulty of the times ahead cannot
be overemphasized again I can't help
thinking that it was never more
eloquently put then
Tom Penn put it writing in the winter of
Valley Forge and another difficult time
for this country when he said these are
the times that try men's souls the
sunshine patriot in the summer soldier
will in this crisis shrink from the
service of his country but he that
stands it now will learn the love and
thanks of man and woman that's why I
think perfect for a starter
why don't we sometimes refer to it as
the white question it's an American
question it is the white question I
think that's one of the things it's
cooked that is what you think so it's
just a human question yes because the in
the ebb and flow of human events these
things come and go conflicts of this
kind come and go there is a renaissance
of democratic spirit the Negroes are
giving us a lesson now that we have been
that we've been waiting for with a
little stale gotten a little fat one
country's up one control-z to think of
it Marlon there's the Negro question was
the Negro dream it what is agree with
that no possibility it is I don't think
it's just a question of smell I think
the responsibility has shifted to the
white people other man Joe well I think
we may all agree we seem to be in
agreement that it's not a question of
semantics but that words often get in
the way of what we mean to say mr.
Pritchett corrected himself when he said
Negro problem and then he changed it to
Negro question he was weighing his words
very carefully what I think I think it
applied in Negro problem is a kind of
suggestion that I represent a problem I
do not represent a problem that you
follow Negros Honor I think
and I swear a problem to the Negro it's
not the same thing at all and this is
this is what I have become aware of
correct because because the person who
hauls of his hands the power to fulfill
the American dream to fulfill the words
of Tom Paine to fulfill the words of the
Declaration of Independence happens to
be a person who is white yes it's only a
white problem is to is to deny the
burning interest of every every fellow
Negro citizen the first talk is such
that what you're saying which I think
everybody wants to hear is being lost
all of your words of wisdom but maybe we
can end it on this point how would you
phrase yourself very briefly now as
succinctly as you can put the essence of
your thought what is the nature of this
question today what is the most
important thing to be done and by each
and every one of us if you had the right
to say I James blogger will tell people
what to do and how to solve this thing
what would you say my god yes nothing
three words no a single thing for
example I happen to think just give you
an idea what I'm getting at that the
most important thing at the moment now
is his job that's quite true but the the
but the nature the problem as I see it
is so complex one can't simply say jobs
when I say job schools houses it's a
whole complex of things you know jobs on
jobs alone one side with schools loan
insolvent it's a it's in the social
fabric you know there ain't anything
it's everything it's everything I really
think to come back to Joe's point in
another way and at the risk of sounding
mystical that the first step probably
has to be somewhere in the American
conscience I think the American the
American like Republic has to ask itself
why was necessary for them to invent the
[ __ ] you know I am NOT a [ __ ]
you know I never called myself one but
you one comes into the world in the
world but the world decides that you are
this for its own reasons and it is very
important I think that's for the
American in terms of in terms of the
future in terms of his health in terms
of the transformation we are all seeking
then he faced this question that he
needed the liver for something you know
may I please be forgiven for
interrupting in fact we have run out of
time but it's kind of a good point
because what you've ended up with us to
say we've all got to face the question I
think what we've done you have just
witnessed an unrehearsed discussion by
those whose deeply held personal views
have committed them to the cause of
civil rights